the last person to see American Teenager
Natalie Holloway alive in Aruba is due
to face a judge today in Birmingham
Alabama his name is Johan vandersload he
was brought there yesterday from a
prison in Peru where he's serving 28
years for murdering a woman back in
2010. now he is not charged with killing
Natalie Holloway who has declared dead
several years ago instead he's accused
of trying to profit from her
disappearance Janet shamlian is in
Birmingham with more on this story Janet
good morning to you I'll never forget
this case
it's been a long time Gail good morning
to you this is the courthouse where we
are expecting to see your in vandersloot
later this morning after he lost a
last-minute appeal fighting his transfer
here to the United States now the
charges that he's going to face here are
not related to the death of Natalie
Holloway but rather for allegedly trying
to extort money from her family
jorn vandersloat flanked by federal
agents arrived in Birmingham Alabama
Thursday the city Natalie Holloway
called home he was the last person to
see the teen alive before she
disappeared on the island of Aruba
during a 2005 High School graduation
trip the case attracted International
attention
vandersloh was twice arrested but never
charged he's long maintained his
innocence then in 2010 a Federal grand
jury indicted the Dutch national
accusing him of trying to extort 250 000
from Holloway's family in exchange for
details about the location of Natalie's
body the information was false Mr
Holloway's concern is he wants the truth
Mark White represents Natalie's father
Dave Holloway these are not murder
charges no so can it be Justice
it can be accountability and perhaps
maybe opportunity for the truth to
finally to come out we'll just have to
see what happens andersloat was seen
smiling as armed police escorted him
from a Lima prison early Thursday Peru
agreed to extradite the 35 year old to
the U.S even though he's still serving a
28-year sentence for the 2010 murder of
21 year old Stephanie Flores Theodore
Simon is an expert on extraditions the
government is acting now in an effort to
avoid lost evidence
trade memories or as yet to determine
variables and certainties that could
complicate and or thwart any future
extradition
Holloway's father in a statement last
month said well nothing can change our
painful reality it is my deep hope that
he will finally speak the truth that we
have searched for over the last 18 years
how has he dealt with this over the past
years
for all of them it has been a living
nightmare
it never goes away it never heals it
never even scars
it just remains an open womb
if convicted vandersloat faces up to 20
years in prison but he would have to
serve that time after he finishes his
murder sentence in Peru he's currently
scheduled to be released from that
country in the year 2038. Vlad
Janet thank you very much you know I
keep thinking about the parents in the
open womb and yes he may not it may not
be justice but just getting the truth
but just to get something and the reason
why this story resonates with so many
here's Natalie Holloway young attractive
a senior in high school going on her
last trip before going off to college
disappearing that night Johan and was
the last person to see her I always
think about Beth Holloway during this
moment and Dave Holloway too the pain
that this that they must be going
through so anything anything that they
get any kind of answer I think would be
helpful and it's unimaginable after 18
years it really is